quarterback moves we'd like to see chris
you get the first pick oh thank you very
much this is nice okay i mean again this
isn't the most realistic thing in the
world but man we're going to have a
draft like this i'm going to have some
fun
i mean what i want to see aaron rodgers
on the 49ers that's what i want to see i
mean is that a realistic enough one to
go with here i mean there's enough
rumors there right i mean i think so but
how could chris sims lose with that
situation right there my favorite
quarterback with my favorite coach on a
really good team rogers goes back to the
bay area you know and gets to be a part
of that and that offense oh my gosh
would i love it i'd be wearing an aaron
rodgers 49ers jersey every thursday on
the show if that was the case
uh that you know you you already are
hard to deal with good lord it would be
a hundred times worse if aaron rodgers
were playing for the san francisco 49ers
but uh hey maybe next year maybe that's
maybe they do a band-aid with someone
for a year and they get in position for
rogers next year it's pretty clear that
the packers yeah and rogers are
connected for one year but not for two
next year it could be very different
i'm gonna go with the guy that we spent
a lot of time talking about earlier in
the hour russell wilson
to
america's team oh dallas cowboys right
now i have no idea what it would take
for the cowboys to get him i don't know
where dak prescott would end up surely
he wouldn't also be on the cowboys but
what a solution that would be to this
never-ending
problem and look at it russell wilson's
contract averages 35 million per year
they got to pay dak prescott 37 million
this year just to keep him with no
commitment beyond this year a 44 raise
to tag him again in 2022
and and as and look
this russell wilson thing is not new
it's it's finally hitting
in a big way but it's been lingering for
a while and the one team that i keep
hearing about when russell wilson's name
comes up and the possibility of leaving
seattle is the cowboys chris well yeah i
i hear you there i mean you know i mean
russell russell wilson to the giants a
few years ago
i think that was a real thing when we
kind of heard that and you know all
those rumors so
again i don't think it's crazy i hear
you there and i might pick russell to
another team here a little later on in
the draft um
i think i'm gonna go with the desean
watson
i don't know what team to pick here i'm
stuck in between but for the for the for
the sake of f i'll go with the patriots
i'd love to see deshaun do that that
would be a lot of fun he has knowledge
of that offense except this would be
even more diverse and he would have to
learn more of it but man a guy like him
a year after brady went to the bucks and
won the super bowl now the patriots make
this type of move to get this type of
quarterback and of course we know they
need some weapons around to help them
but they got a lot of money to spend
it's hard that one jumps out to me uh it
does and i think it would be fun
watson becomes a potential magnet for
free agents he does you know
that the patriots have plenty of cap
space right and and and you know you
could have that tom brady dynamic in new
england where other guys want to go join
desean watson and they're not going to
sweat the idea that you know it's no fun
playing for bill belichick we want to be
with deshawn we want to build something
special we want to chase championships
okay so assuming that the texans are
smart enough to move on from desean
watson they'll need a quarterback
i'd love to see derek carr
to the houston texans for a variety of
reasons one of which is david carr was
the first quarterback in franchise
history
and the texans are kind of dysfunctional
right now so i'd kind of like to see how
car would exist in that environment and
the whole separation from the raiders
would be newsworthy now
the raiders have gotten calls about
derek carr and the raiders have resisted
but you know
there there may be something there and
wouldn't it be great if the texans
decide they're going to backfill
their quarterback position by getting
derek carr it literally it really would
be i mean it would be cool uh there's no
doubt about that
i think um you know
he's got he's a texan first off the fans
would you know latch on to that and be
around that certainly there's no doubt
and we know hey the raiders gruden he's
always he's always flirting he's always
looking for somebody else i will say
because i mean i know
what was it what did i read yesterday
but david carr right said that you know
they've got the the raiders have gotten
calls on derrick there and everything
like that said that yeah i just said
that you weren't listening sorry you
were too busy trying to figure out your
next you're right i'm sorry but i had a
point i was gonna make anyways either
ways just go i just can't imagine the
raiders letting him go at this point i
mean maybe if something came about but
man gruden's finally got his robot wired
to run his offense i would think he'd be
a little reluctant to trade him not that
i don't think your thing's a great idea
and sorry i repeated that you're right
let me say this let me say this though
i've heard
from a source that i trust that the
raiders are not going to trade him but
i've yet to report it at pft because i
still think even under those
circumstances you can't rule out john
gruden catching a wild hair
i i totally agree with you there i mean
you're right you can't rule you can't
rule that out i think my last one i'm
gonna go russell wilson to the colts
okay i didn't get to i'm gonna i'm gonna
use him one yeah i know but
they're ready
you know again
tampa wasn't looked at as this place of
like oh i want to go live there it's
this shining beacon but now it looks
pretty damn cool doesn't it yeah you
know boat parades so okay i know sierra
and russell wilson it might not be like
indianapolis type of people but damn
that offense some of the weapons they
got there that o line frank wright's
creativity i think that could put them
right in the super bowl conversation
i'm torn between kirk cousins to the
49ers
i think i think kirk cousins the 49ers
is far more realistic than aaron rodgers
and the vikings are in a tough spot here
and cousins last week with a smile on
his face he made it clear to us during
pftpm he's not signing an extension with
the vikings he's gonna he's gonna let
i'm gonna go cousins to the 49ers pete
he's going to let this play out and he's
going to have tremendous leverage in two
years he's going to be back on the open
market and if the vikings don't trade
him a 35 million fully guaranteed salary
for 2022 vests on march 19. i now the
problem is who do the vikings be yeah
what are you going to do nice i think
you'd have to bring home teddy
bridgewater yeah i think that's your
only alternative what no
i thought that was pete that but no i
wasn't making that
yeah maybe i should have said teddy
bridgewater the vikings that's the other
half of it kirk cousins of the 49ers
teddy bridgewater to the vikings that's
how that would play out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports